[Música]
el presidente joe biden dijo que para
este 4 de julio eeuu no solo celebraría
su independencia como nación sino que
comenzaría a marcar su independencia del
joven 19 el mandatario ordenó a los
estados a facilitar la vacunación de
todos los adultos para el primero de
mayo el anuncio de bailén se da tras
promulgar su plan de rescate de 1.9
billones de dólares
a pesar de una exitosa campaña de
vacunación si le imponen nuevas
restricciones para frenar los nuevos
brotes de joven 19 entre ellas habrá
cuarentena para los viajeros de brasil
el país más afectado de américa latina'
que por segundo día consecutivo
sobrepasó los 2 mil muertos la cifra más
alta desde que se tiene registro
al menos 12 personas más murieron por
disparos de las fuerzas de seguridad de
mi amar este jueves de acuerdo con la
oroya serían al menos 70 los muertos que
ha dejado la represión a las protestas
contra el golpe de estado del pasado
primero de febrero la junta militar
agregó nuevos cargos contra la líder de
puesta on sanssouci que podrían
prolongar su detención
bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo de
france 24 los saluda andrés meza muñoz
iniciamos las noticias en eeuu en su
primer discurso a la nación desde la
casa blanca joe biden tras objetivos
claros para superar la crisis sanitaria
cuando el mundo conmemoró un año de la
pandemia y el país recordó sus primeros
cierres el mandatario anunció que todos
los adultos del país serían elegibles
para vacunarse a partir del primero de
mayo y que espera recuperar una cierta
de normalidad para el próximo 4 de julio
más romeros tiene los detalles
y ya es una realidad el presidente
demócrata joe biden convirtió en ley el
plan de rescate para paliar la crisis
económica dejada por la pandemia 19
billones de dólares en ayudas y
estímulos
era una de las puntas de lanza de la
campaña de bailén durante las elecciones
una promesa cumplida menos de dos meses
después de su llegada a la casa blanca
la ley incluye pagos directos de 1400
dólares a los estadounidenses que
ingresen menos de 75 mil dólares anuales
una suma mayor a la de los planes
anteriores firmados por trump también
dará ayudas semanales de 300 dólares a
las personas sin empleo hasta el fin del
verano y otorgará ayudas millonarias a
gobiernos locales además de prever
partidas para reabrir las escuelas
impulsar el plan de vacunación y
aumentar las pruebas de kobe 19 además
cumplió otra promesa
dije que quería inyectar 100 millones de
dosis durante mis primeros 100 días de
gobierno esta noche puedo decir que no
sólo alcanzaremos ese objetivo sino que
lo superaremos porque estamos en camino
de lograr las 100 millones de dosis en
mis primeros 60
sixty de noche
esta noche anuncio que dirijo todos los
estados y territorios para que todos los
adultos mayores de 18 años sean
elegibles para vacunarse el primero de
mayo de neiva el objetivo del demócrata
que se apunta a otra victoria durante
sus primeros meses en la casa blanca es
que los estadounidenses puedan celebrar
el 4 de julio día de la independencia
con una cierta normalidad en sus propias
palabras que eeuu se independice del
virus
vamos a américa latina' por segundo día
consecutivo brasil superó los 2.000
muertos por kobe 19 la cifra más alta
desde que inició la pandemia las
autoridades sanitarias advirtieron que
los hospitales en las principales
ciudades del país están a punto de
alcanzar su límite brasil tiene el 3% de
la población mundial y el 10 por ciento
de los muertos por kobe 19 en todo el
planeta
en este contexto chile impuso cuarentena
para los viajeros provenientes del
gigante latinoamericano la medida hace
parte de un nuevo paquete de
restricciones para frenar los posibles
nuevos brotes del virus a pesar de una
exitosa campaña de vacunación en
comparación al resto de latinoamérica si
le pide a su población no bajar la
guardia
sigan protegiendo se es el mensaje de
las autoridades chilenas que advierten
que a pesar de que alrededor del 25% de
la población ha recibido ya al menos una
dosis de la vacuna los ciudadanos no
deben bajar la guardia todavía en la
lucha contra el coronavirus hay que ser
muy prudente tener mucho cuidado de no
caer en el exitismo el gobierno ha
cometido errores en el pasado de
compararse con otras argentinas le daba
lecciones hace un par de meses atrás de
que ellos tenían un mejor sistema
sanitario de la mejor 40 en ellos día
tiene una mortalidad estado chileno
comerá hoy el error para ayudar a
detener un mayor aumento de nuevos casos
chile ha introducido medidas de
cuarentena para todos los viajeros
procedentes de brasil el país más
afectado por la pandemia de américa
latina a partir de hoy día a las 5 de la
mañana todos los viajeros que llegaron
que llegan desde brasil o que han estado
en brasil los últimos 14 días deben irse
a una residencia sanitaria tanto
chilenos como extranjeros en la
residencia sanitaria se les tomará una
pcr y aquellos personas que salen
negativo pueden continuar su cuarentena
en el aislamiento donde está decidido
por las personas las personas que salen
positiva en establecer deben continuar
su aislamiento en la residencia
sanitaria esto se produce cuando las
salas de la uci con pacientes de
coronavirus informaron de un promedio de
ocupación del 93 5% y algunas regiones
informaron de hasta un 18% más de casos
de kobin en los últimos días hasta el
jueves chile ha registrado más de 860
mil casos de kobe y más de 21 mil
muertos
pasamos a argentina siete focos de
incendios dejan millonarias pérdidas en
el sur del país en las provincias de río
negro y chubut el fuego destruyó más de
dos mil hectáreas de bosque en la región
patagónica entre 200 y 300 casas
quedaron inhabitables y por lo menos 11
personas siguen desaparecidas y 30
resultaron heridas según las autoridades
los presuntos autores de los incendios
formarían parte de una organización
mapuche radical más en el informe de
andrea maya porras
cientos de familias argentinas lo
perdieron todo ropa recuerdos comida
elementos de trabajo todo se lo llevó el
fuego la amenaza se veía lejana pero los
focos de incendio empezaron a
multiplicarse y rápidamente consumieron
cientos de casas en la provincia de
chubut
en la llamada comarca andina que reúne a
las provincias de río negro y chubut
los focos siguen activos en el último
reporte de incendios del ministerio de
ambiente de argentina otras provincias
también son víctimas de las llamas
muchos focos lograron ser controlados el
miércoles gracias a las lluvias pero el
jueves el viento volvió a soplar y las
llamas que resurgieron arrasaron con la
poca vegetación que había sobrevivido
según el diario clarín los presuntos
autores de los siete focos de incendio
en la comarca andina son tres personas
que integran agrupaciones militares
mapuche y radicalizadas el ministro de
ambiente presentó una denuncia penal ya
que asegura se trata de una situación
que fue planificada está llegando un
cuerpo de peritos de la policía federal
de argentina solicitado por la justicia
para que haga un relevamiento y pueda
detectar material combustible lo que
daría cuenta de la intencionalidad de
los focos ígneos las previsiones para
este viernes apuntan a condiciones
meteorológicas favorables sin embargo se
espera un aumento de las temperaturas el
fin de semana
al menos 12 manifestantes más murieron
en mi amar este jueves tras recibir
disparos de las fuerzas de seguridad de
acuerdo con naciones unidas ya serían al
menos 70 los muertos que ha dejado la
represión a las protestas que rechazan
el golpe de estado del pasado primero de
febrero el relator especial de la onu
sobre la situación de derechos humanos
en mianmar reportó que desde esa fecha
el número de arrestos y detenciones
arbitrarias han aumentado a más de 2000
al tiempo que denuncia crímenes de lesa
humanidad la junta militar acusó a la
líder de puesta a un sanssouci de haber
recibido barras de oro y pagos
irregulares por unos 600.000 dólares por
parte de un aliado político entre 2017 y
2018 un nuevo cargo que podría prolongar
su detención
jean-marc está siendo controlado por un
régimen ilegal y asesinó su liderazgo
actual perpetuo crímenes atroces que son
el foco del cargo por genocidio ante la
corte internacional de justicia y como
lo documente en el anexo de mi reporte
los crímenes contra el pueblo rojilla
continua streaming en vivo con singh
y estrés del golpe de estado los
militares de mianmar han atacado y
desplazado a miles de miembros de
nacionalidades étnicas de sus hogares
bulgaria es el último en sumarse a una
lista de países que decidieron suspender
el uso de la vacuna de astrazéneca tras
los reportes sobre coágulos de sangre en
algunas personas que recibieron la
inyección en europa el gobierno búlgaro
dice que esperar a un informe de la
agencia europea de medicamentos que
disipe estas preocupaciones que la
farmacéutica niega tailandia decidió
retrasar el inicio de su plan de
inoculación con este fármaco que estaba
programado para hoy
dinamarca noruega e islandia ya habían
suspendido su aplicación mientras que
otros como alemania francia y reino
unido- defendieron su seguridad
hasta aquí esta informativa en france 24
quédense con nosotros
[Música]